ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد ذكر موقع ان
اداره الرئيس الامريكي جبارين ابلغت رئيس
الوزراء العراقي الجديد محمد شاهين
السوداني بانها لن تتعامل مع الوزراء
والمسؤولين المتهمين لفصائل صنفت هو
واشنطن على قائمه الارهاب وقال الموقع
نقلا عن مصدرين مطلعين ان من بين هؤلاء
الوزراء وزير التعليم العالي الجديد نعيم
العبودي الذي قالت انه ينتمي لعصائب اهل
الحق التي تصنف امريكا
بالقلق بشان ربيع نادر الذي تم تعينه
لرئاسه المكتب الصحافي السوداني حيث عمل
مع وسائل الاعلام تابعه لعناصر عصائب اهل
الحق معاك كتائب الحزبه واجتمعت سفيره
الامريكيه في العراق الينا رمانوفسكي مع
السوداني خمس مرات منذ ان تولى منصبه بحسب
مصدرين وقالت المصادر ان روما نفسكي ابلغت
السو بس سياسه الامريكيه في التعامل مع
وزراء الحكومه والمسؤولين المرتبطين
بالميليشياته مشيرتان الى ان اداره بايظه
راضيه عن الخيرات البناء مع السوداني الذي
شهدته حتى الان واضافت المصادر ان تصرفات
السودانيسا تحكم على استقلالها عن النفوذ
الايرانيه كما اشارت الى ان اداره بيضاء
قلقه من ان السوداني لن يكون لديه سيطره
كثيره على الميليشيات الشرعيه
واضافت المصادر انه اذا زادت الميليشيات
منها هجماتها على القوات الامريكيه في
العراق فقط يغير ذلك سياسه اداره بيدنا
اتجاه الحكومه العراقيه
واوراق هانسى يا بطل
لا يريدون امه بقياده ميليشيات مسلحه بل
يؤمنون بانهم يستحقون دوله تسيطر على
سلاحي وحكومه يمكن ان توفر لهم الامن
والاستقرار والنمو الاقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفي من بغداد
الدكتور حسين علاوي المستشار الحكوميه
اهلا بك من بغداد وثق الجابريه الباحث
السياسي اهلا بيكوا من واشنطن حسين عبد
الحسين البحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن
الديمقراطيات اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
واسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع الجهه الرسميه
الحضره معنا اليوم مع الدكتور حسين علاوي
دكتور حسين اهلا بك معنا لقراءه اوليه من
جهه رسميه لهذه التصريحات في الواقع
تصريحات السفير الامريكيه لدى العراق التي
تقول بان العراقيين لا يردون ان يحكموا من
ميليشيات حضرتك همم
كيف تقرا هكذا تصريح من وجهه نظر رسميا
يعني مساء الخير عليكم
همم اكيد الان العلاقات العراقيه
الامريكيه هي علاقات متقدمه وهنالك دعم
كبير من قبل الحكومه الامريكيه الى السيد
رئيس وزراء محمد الشيعه السوداني وكذلك
بالمقابل لحظنا الاتصال الذي جرى بين وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي وكذلك السيد رئيس وزراء
وكان واضح جدا انه هنالك دعم لخطوات
الاصلاح وكذلك مكافحه الفساد وكذلك
العلاقات الدفاعيه والامنيه ما بعد انتقال
المهام وكذلك في تقديم الاستشاره والتدريب
وكذلك الان كان هنالك اليوم اتصال هاتفي
من قبل رئيس حلف الناتو كذلك مع السيد
رئيس وزراء القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
فبالتالي العلاقات همم جيده وفعاله وتسير
بالاتجاه الصحيح لكن ما اريد ان يعطب عليه
حقيقه هو ان التقرير الذي الان كتب ولم
يصدر من واشنطن ولم يصدر من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه حتى نقول ان هذا
التقرير في دقه للمعلومات وبالتالي
المعلومات هي معلومات مغلو لان كل الان
الوزراء هم التزمين في المنهاج الوزاري
لرئيس الوزراء وكذلكم مسؤولين امام
البرلمان في تنفيذ المنهاج الوزاري
والبرنامج الحكومي الذي سيصدر في اطار
المنهاج الوزاري الذي خطه السيد رئيس
الوزراء وكذلكم مسؤولين مسؤوليه اخلاقيه
امام الشعب العراقي في عمليه الاصلاح
وقياده الدوله نحو تنفيذ الاهداف الاساسيه
التي
تسلميه وهذا صحيح
صحيحه ومعلومات
لان نفس هذا الموقع مثلا صدقه في مره
سابقه لما تحدث
بتاكل كذلك ضيوفي بانه همم مع بدايه
التظاهرات لو تتذكر تدهورت صدره في العراق
كانت هناك تحضيرات من واقع اكسيوس بانه
همم
السياسيون الامريكيون يحضرون من حرب
الاهليه وبعده بفتره وجيزه فعلا صدرت
تصريحات همم يعني تحدث بها الامريكان وحذر
ومن هذه الحرب الاهليه ولكن عن دقه هذا
المصدر ساسال ضيف يا دكتور حسين عبد حسين
دكتور حسين ما ذكره موقع اكسيوس من ان
هناك تحضيرات امريكيه للحكومه العراقيه
همم التي تعتمد في بعض مناصبها على
مجموعات منسوبين على الميليشيات هل ترى
دقه فيما ينشر
مساء الخير ستريم ارى دقه كامله في ما
تنشر طبعا موقع اكسيوس يديروا الصحافي
المعروف مايكل وهو صاحب يعني
علاقات واسعه جدا ويعني عدد منا سمع
الكلام نفسه من المسؤولين الامريكيين انه
لا تتعامل الولايات المتحده مع التنظيمات
الارهابيه او مع اي محسوب على هذه
التنظيمات
التي تصنفها الولايات المتحده ارهابيه همم
وهذا النموذج هو نفس النموذج التي تطبقه
الولايات المتحده في تعاملها مع دوله
لبنان ومع حكومه لبنان هي تتعامل مثلا مع
رئيس حكومه لبنان ولكن لا تتعامل مع
الوزراء الذين ينتمون لحزب الله الذي
تصنفه الولايات المتحده ارهابي فالموضوع
ليس حديثا والموضوع يعني ليس ضد السيد
السوداني الموضوع دقيق وهو يقول انه نحن
لن نتعامل مع اي اعضاء في تنظيمات ارهابيه
في الحكومه العراقيه او خارج الحكومه نعم
استاذ واثق حضرتك كيف ترى الموضوع هل هو
خطاب مباشر للحكومه العراقيه او هي همم
تصريحات موجهه
لطرف ثالث نتحدث عن ايران انا البعض كذلك
يقول من هذه الميليشيات التي صنفتها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ارهابيه هذه
ميليشيات تتبع او تقتات بقياده ايرانيه
طبعا اكيد طبعا اعضض كلام دكتور حسين انه
الكلام الذي صدره وليس بتصريح رسمي ولم
يصدر من وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه هذه اول
الولايات المتحده تتعامل
حسين لا دكتور حسين علاوي
يعني
التقرير طبعا الحكومه الامريكيه تتعامل مع
حكومه العراق والحكومه العراقيه لديها
علاقات جيده مع الولايات المتحده وهنالك
تطبيقات يعني من قبل السيد السوداني
للولايات المتحده والدول الاقليميه
والعلاقات جيده جدا الولايات المتحده لا
يمكن لها ان تتعامل بشكل قطاع يعني مع
قطاعات وانما تتعامل مع الحكومه والحكومه
لها رؤيه اضافه الى ذلك كل القوه السياسيه
المنخرطه في الحكومه سواء كانت يعني حتى
التي يمكن انه صنفوها لديها فصار فسلحه او
غيرها من همم مشاكل ذلك هي تنخرط ضمن
البرنامج الحكومي وحتى ما ذكر همم السيد
ربيع في رئاسه الوزراء هو الذي يكون
التعيين جديدا وانما كان في حكومه ربيع
نادر كان في حكومه
السيد الكاظمي وحكومه عبد المهدي وتدرج في
العمل الوظيفي
الاحد بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه همم
ليست لديها علاقات متينه مع حكومه بغداد
ولكن الموضوع او الاستفهام اا لا يتعلق
بحكومه السيد السوداني الموضوع يتعلق
بتصريحات تاتي الان وكان همم صبر
الامريكيين قد نفذ فيما يخص التداخل
الايراني خلينا نقولها بصراحه التدخل
الايراني فشل العراقي ومن هنا اتت تصريحات
وحتى بالاسماء غريب انه موقع كهذا يتحدث
الدكتور حسين عبد الحسين عن دقه يتحدث
بالاسماء همم اا يجب ان يكون هناك شيء من
الصحه في
الفاضله يعني اولا يعني حتى سيد ربيع نادر
يعني هو هو ليس يعني منتمينا الى هذا
الفصيل وانما هو عمل وكثير من الاعلاميين
الذين يعملون في محطاته وسائل الاعلام
تابعه للجهاد سياسي لكن يعملون ضمن
التخصصهم وليس ضمن يعني انتمائهم الحزبي
وبالتالي هو اختير على هذا الاساس اللي
همم الشيء الثاني يعني الحكومه العراقيه
او حتى الوزراء الجدد يعني مهما تكون جهه
انتماءهم يتعاملون على اساس حكومه
ويتعاملون
يعني حضرتك اريد
تقنعني او تقني عن المشاهدين بانه المناصب
في العراق همم لا تسند همم على حساب او
همم على اساس الحلقات
لا لا لا هي هي اصلا تقسم بين الاحزاب
السياسيه لكن هذا لا يعني ان القوى
السياسيه السيد السودان اليوم هو يعني حتى
لديه رقابه مشدده على وزرائه وهم كلهم
منخرطون ضمن البرنامج الحكومي بالتالي
اعود لك من جديد دكتور حسين عبد الحسين
ضيوفي يقولون بانه ليس هناك جديد يذكر هذا
الموقع لا يحمل اي شيء همم من الصدق اي
شيء من الدقه فهل حضرتك تعتبر بان تصريحات
السفير الامريكيه لدى بغداد فيه تلميح
يؤكد ما جاء في هذا الموقع لانه هي قالت
بان العراقيين لا يردون ان يحكموا همم عن
طريق ميليشيات او من ميليشيات فهل هذا
تلميح وس- اا ياتي فيما بعده همم تصريحات
همم صريحه نكون امامها تعتقد
حتما لا اعتقد انه الولايات المتحده بحاجه
الى تلميح اعتقد انه المسؤولين الامريكيين
يقولون هذه المواضيع بصراحه يعني لا خجل
عند الامريكيين انه ان يقولوا هذا وزير
ينتمي لمجموعه نصنفها ارهابيه ولا نتعامل
معه بعدين غير صحيح انه الجمهوريات الدول
او الحكومات تتعامل يعني فقط راس حكومه
الى راس حكومه هناك تعامل بين العراق
والولايات المتحده على الاقل هناك تعامل
على صعيد الجيش الى الجيش والاستخبارات مع
الاستخبارات وهناك قطاعات تنميه ناشطه
امريكيه تتعامل بشكل مباشر مع الوزارات
وهذه الحال في كل الدول يعني مثلا نانسي
فلوسي زهره تايوان من دون علم الاداره
يعني الموضوع ليس انه قبيله هنا وقبيله
هناك الولايات المتحده اعمل مع عدد كبير
من الوزارات عراقيه والوكالات الفيدراليه
في بغداد وهي واضحه انه ان كان اي من
الوزراء ينتمي الى اي من تنظيمات التي
تصنفها الولايات المتح ارهابيه وتابع
لايران لن نتعامل معها اعتقد يعني لو قمنا
بسؤال الاداره بشكل بشكل مباشر لن تلمع
ستقولها صراحه وربما قالتها صراحه وراء
الابواب المغلقه هكذا يقول البعض في
تعليقه على ما جاء على موقع اكسيوس ولكن
دكتور علاوي همم هل همم اذا صدقت همم هذه
التصريحات او على الاقل هذه الاخبار التي
حملها موقع اكس يمكن ان نتحدث عن همم
مرحله جديده في العلاقه بين واشنطن وبغداد
او على الاقل مش مرحله جديده حتى لا نحمل
الامور اكثر مما تحمل ولكن على تاثيرات ان
همم ساعه بغداد الى انتاج نفس النهج
لا اولا انا فقط اريد ان اعود مره اخرى
الى القصه عندما لا توجد ذلك القصه لبعض
الادوات الاعلام الغربي الذي يصنع همم
بنموذج البابل او
الخبر المنفوخ الذي يخرج ونرى من سيقع او
يفجر هذا الخبر هنالك مشكله كبيره الان
حقيقه في هذا الموضوع هنالك مسار وسلوك
ورؤيه واضحه يعني سعاده السفير الامريكيه
هنا في العاصمه بغداد كانت واضحه جدا في
اللقاء الذي اجراها السيد ماجد حقيقه
الحميد معها وكانت توضح ان العلاقات
والمسار واضح جدا وضيفنا الان من واشنطن
كذلك يتحدث ان العلاقات منتظمه ما بين
المؤسسات السياسيه والاقتصاديه والامنيه
مع المؤسسات المناظره من قبل المساعدات
التي تقدم الى العراق وهي جهد فني وتقني
وكذلك في ضوء اتفاقيه الاطار الاستراتيجي
وبالتالي العلاقات منتظمه من الصعب جدا
الان الحكم حقيقي على ان العلاقه ستعكر
هنالك اسرار من قبل الطرفين ان تمضي
العلاقات نحو افق جديد وهذا الافق الجديد
يكون ويدعم المنهاج الوزاري الذي يركز
الان على التنميه يدعم الحكومه التي هي
تمثل ائتلاف سياسي متعدد الطوائف
والقوميات والاعراب وهنا واضح جدا هذا
الموضوع وكذلك لاول مره نجد ان رئيس
الحكومه وكذلك اعضاء الحكومه هم يمثلون من
منهاج جديد يختلف عن الحكومات السابقه
سواء من حيث الاطار السياسي او من حيث
التضامن السياسي ومن حيث كذلك المشاكل
التي يواجهها العراق وهي مشاكل كبيره امام
السيد رئيس وزران كانت امام التنميه او
امام الاقتصاد ولكن بالعوده لتصريحات سفير
الامريكيه بالعراق حضرتك ترى فيها وضوح
البعض سيقول لك بانه ارى فيها تلميح ارى
فيها تلميح وارى فيها تقاربا مع ما همم
همم
قراناه على موقع اكسيوس يعني مثلا السفير
الامريكيه في العراق تقول ان العراقيين لا
يريدون ان تقودهم من الاشياء حدثنا عن ذلك
همم تقول كذلك بانه وسؤالي حظرتك استاذ
واثق تقول كذلك سفير الامريكي في العراق
من المهم قيام حكومه السوداني بالسيطره
على السلاح همم وبان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كانت واضحه في تاكيد بقائها
بالعراق ونامل في نجاح حكومه السوداني
بالوصول الى عراق مزدهر حديث عن
الميليشيات وحديث عن السلاح هذا يضعنا
تقريبا في نفس اطار المخاوف التي يعيشها
البعض في داخل العراق ويؤكد ربما ما جاء
في موقع اكسيس ما رايك
نعم يعني هو مساله حصل سلاح بيد الدوله
يعني هذا الشعار رفعته يعني كل الحكومات
وكل القوى السياسيه ربما هي اشبه بالمتفق
على على هذه النقطه لكن هي تختلف بطبيعه
الاليات ومن هي الجهات التي يمكن ان يحصل
سلاحها
بالتالي يعني الحكومه العراقيه يعني الضيف
من واشنطن تحدث ان الحكومه الامريكيه
لديها اتفاقات الامنيه والتدريب الاتفاقات
لا تتم الا من خلال رئيس مجلس الوزراء وهو
الذي يرسم السياسه الخارجيه والداخليه
للدوله
لا يتم الاتفاق مع اي دوله بشكل قطاع لذلك
يعرف مساله التخوف
والتخوف يعني التخوف الامريكي ربما هو
خوفا يقدم هؤلاء الوزراء على تعاقدات يعني
مع دول او خارق الاتفاقيات الموجوده مع
الولايات المتحده لكن الحكومه العراقيه
وحكومه السيد السوداني انا قلت هي في
بدايه قبل او قبل التكليف هي طمعانه
الاطراف الدوليه والاقليميه والق سياسي
ايضا كل السياسي وانا سمعتها من قبل كل
قاده الاطار انهم يقولون سنمضي على وفقه
سياسات التي تخدم مصلحه العراق وليس على
اساس تعاملات يعني او تاثيرات اقليميه او
دوليه اي انهم لن ينخرطوا ضمن محور من
محاور على حساب محور اخر اي ان العلاقات
مع الولايات المتحده ستبقى علاقات جيده
بقيه الدول ستبقى علاقات متوازنه لا تتاثر
بالسياسه وزير او سياسه حزب هذه السياسه
التي رسمتها حكومه السيد السيستاني
الدكتور عبد الحسين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا ترحل عشان
في قول الامور همم كما هي بصراحه فهل
تعتقد بان همم ما تضمنه موقع اكسيس ان صدق
طبعا وان كان في شيء من الدقه هو موجه
لحكومه السوداني او مواجهه لايران نفسه
اللي سالته الاستاذ قليل
هو موجه للاثنين معا ما تزال هناك مشكله
الميليشيات الامن في العراق قبل اسبوع او
اكثر اعتقد
قامت الميليشيات بقتل مواطن امريكي اسمه
ستيفن ترول يعمل مع وكاله التنميه في نصف
بغداد وهذا موضوع يقلق الحكومه الامريكيه
يعني طبعا هي تحاول ان تصل التحقيقات الى
نتائج ولكنها تعرف انه هذه الحكومه
العراقيه غير قادره على ضبط المنشات هناك
عدد من الخطوات التي وعد بها السيد
السوداني خصوصا للجهات الامريكيه منها همم
سحب الجيش او سحب من الشات وتسليم امن
المدن الكبرى خصوصا بغداد للشرطه الشرطه
الفيدراليه خصوصا يعني هناك عدد من
الافكار ولكن من الممكن الحكم على اداء
السيد السوداني تجاه المهم في من وجهه
الامريكيه هو حاصر استخدام العنف بايدي
الحكومه المنتخبه وهذا طبعا الموضوع الذي
همم طهران وارفع عرضه المليشيات المواليه
الى طهران ان في لبنان او في العراق او في
اليمن او غيره فاع
تقد هذا تواصل
الضغط على بغداد لتحقيق السياده بايدي
الحكومه العراقيه من دون النساء
وبعيدا عن الدبلوماسيه سماح ليه من بين
تصريحات الاخرى للسفير الامريكيه في بغداد
لقناه العربيه قالت كذلك بانه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه باقيه في العراق وهذا
لن يرضي ايران فكيف ستمسك بغداد العصا من
الوسط
لا اكيد هو واضح جدا انه نهج السياسه
الخارجيه العراقيه سيكون مستقل يعني كون
انه السمات الشخصيه الان الرئيس الوزراء
هو مستقل هو مفوض من قبل القوى السياسيه
العراقيه وواضح جدا في المنهاج الوزاري
هنالك قد تجري مفاوضات عميقه على عمليه
انه التركيز على قضيه بناء القدرات القوات
المسلحه العراقيه والاتفاق ذلك في هذا
المسار في اطار اتفاقيه الاطار
الاستراتيجي وهذا بالتالي ما يجعل كذلك
بالمقابل الايرانيين واضحين جدا عندما زار
السفير الايراني السيد رئيس الوزراء كان
واضح جدا ان انا مستقله وانتم مستقلون
وتسيرون همم
مستشار الحكوميه الاستاذ واسق الجابريال
بحث السياسيه والدكتور حسين عبد الحسين
البحث في مؤسسه الدفاع عن الديمقراطيه
شكرا لكم
السلام عليكم